Finally, Sunshine has multiple activities
and we can move between them
using InTense.
We also know how to use Implicit InTense
to integrate activities from other apps.
In this lesson, we'll dive into
just how the Android framework
deals with your activities, in particular,
how the activity life cycle
maybe different from what you're used to
from other platforms and environments.
Don't worry, there's plenty of code
for you to write.
Yes. Plenty of code.
Lots and lots, and lots of code.
We'll move Sunshine along,
implementing an underlying database
and wrapping that in a content provider.
Everything you need to know
to use persistent storage.
The goal is to ensure your app provides
a seamless, efficient experience
for your users, even when networks
may be slow or unavailable